Two women just graduated from Army Ranger
school, starting the all-too-familiar debate
of women in combat.
After more than 10 years of war, with women
participating alongside: is there any science
that says they shouldn't be all that they
can be?
When First Lt. Shaye Haver and Capt. Kristen
Griest passed the nine-week training program
to become Army Rangers, they made history,
but they also made the news.
Ranger School is the Army's most rigorous
training program.
36 percent of attendees fail in the first
four days, and only 42 percent will finally
walk away with the black-and-gold Ranger tab.
But even though these women passed all the
tests, they still may not see combat.
In January of 2013, then-Sec of Defense Leon
Panetta announced the end of male-only combat,
requiring women be allowed to serve in combat
roles by January 2016.
Many argue that women aren't ready for frontline
combat, or simply cannot manage the hell that
is war, and as the equality train hits the
voting booth, the bedroom, the workplace,
and onward: the theater of war is yet another
stop.
After Panetta's order, the armed forces began
conducting studies and assessing standards
to see if sex integration will be the future
of our military.
Women have been part of fighting forces for
decades in Sri Lanka's Tamil Tigers, Ireland's
IRA, and soldiering in Sierra Leone.
But now, the U.S. has to determine if they
can open the remaining 220,000 men-only jobs
to women too.
According to military data, three things are
important for combat readiness: mental health,
physical capability, and proper training.
A National Center for PTSD study in 2011,
found men and women developed mental health
issues equally after "combat, firing a weapon
in combat, being fired upon, handling human
remains and witnessing injury and death,"
but men were more likely to fall into substance
abuse.
Those findings were supported by another study
in the Journal of Psychiatric Research.
But a 2006 study of women and men in combat,
found emotional responses were different,
and quote "in stressful situations, men are
more likely to resort to physically aggressive
responses than women," and according to a
piece in TIME by Pulitzer Prize-winning reporter
Mark Thompson, "aggression leads to more accidents
and injuries in men" It would seem, mentally,
women can hack it as well as men, and may
handle some things better, as they don't abuse
substances, become aggressive, or injure themselves
due to stress.
Physically, though, women have less upper
body strength than men overall; according
to a 2004 U.S. Army study.
Women do have smaller hearts, skeletons and
muscle mass, and a greater percentage of body
fat relative to their male colleagues; which
ups the injury rate significantly.
Injuries are anything that takes a servicemember
out of combat.
Pregnancy adds to women's injury stats, but
even if you remove it from the data -- women
are hospitalized at 30 percent higher rates
than men.
According to data from the Pentagon, men are
hospitalized for general injuries, poisonings,
and disorders of the muscles, skin, or "connective
tissues," while women are hospitalized for
genital and urinary disorders, mental disorder,
and tumors.
With this data in mind, the military is working
to design gender-neutral training programs
and understand injuries.
Even though women, on average, have less strength,
not all women are weaker or prone to injury.
Some females are stronger than males, and
they deserve an equal chance at a combat position.
That is echoed by Army General Martin Dempsey,
chairman of the Joint Chiefs.
According to every statement I read, military
requirements will not be eroded, lowered,
lightened or lessened in any way on the road
to gender neutrality in combat.
Instead, they'll make it "about science and
observation" and ensure people can perform
needed duties.
If so, they get the job.
Period.
According to a 1980 paper assessing women
in combat by Major Thomas H. Cecil, people
should be "allowed to serve in whatever role
that could use best the talent and capability
each individual has."
After racial integration and the repeal of
"Don't Ask; Don't Tell," the military is disrupted
at first, but they gets over it as long as
people are perceived fairly and equally in
training and practice.
There is no evidence males break down when
females are killed or injured in battle, or
are distracted by their fellow female warriors.
As long as the training is equal, our armed
forces are trained to protect each other regardless
of which chromosomes we possess.
Of course, there will be sex between members
of the military, but that is not new at ALL.
GIs in every war we've ever engaged in found
girls abroad, and that tradition continues
with these women too, but the fear comes from
societal stereotypes about female sexuality,
not fact.
In the end, they are servicemembers first
and women second.
Caliber and ability are the currencies of
our armed forces.
As serving females are trained equally and
prove they can do anything fellow males can
do; they will earn the same benefit: to serve
their country as a volunteer in America's
armed forces.
If you want to show your support from home,
start a website and showcase your support
your favorite female servicemember.
No domain extension will help you tell your
story like a DOT COM or DOT NET domain name.
And because you watch DNews, you can get 15%
off Domain Dot Com’s names and web hosting
by using the code DNews when you check out.